let's talk about the halftime show
because for people who are not football
aficionados yeah that's what is also so
extraordinary about this day is there is
something for everyone we live i love
music i love advertising this is my
fantasy day aside from the love of
football 90s hip-hop
literally the kings and queens
it's gonna be huge cnn reports the
trailer alone is epic it stars eminem
snoop mary j blige and kendrick all
receiving a call from dr dre
to unite at sophie stadium in inglewood
and it ends with this incredible dream
team walking towards the stadium with
california love playing in the
background a true ode to tupac and west
coast rap
this is the soundtrack of my life you've
got everything i mean you know carrie
thought
listen you you took the words right out
i grew this is my music i grew up on
this snoop dogg represents so much of
what west coast rap is from its genesis
really truly to it became mainstream and
it's almost as he has called himself the
dog father so you it may it only makes
sense that he and jerry have teamed up
for this super bowl for this special
moment can't wait for that and you know
we're excited for the halftime show for
the super bowl but let's face it what we
all really want everybody is
the puppy bowl
and
oh and people reports that teams have
celeb coaches this year for the puppy
bowl martha stewart is coaching team
ruff
and snoop dogg himself is coaching team
fluff he's all over this super bowl and
this year they have
115 puppies all up for adoption and
guess what everybody we're gonna meet
some of those puppies they're right here
they're here
we've been holding them oh my god i got
so many kisses just like minutes ago
i've been like full blown make out puppy
breath situation nose to nose one bit my
chin
do you know what you call a wide
receiver in the puppy bowl
a golden retriever
all right finally if your favorite part
of super bowl sundays is the commercials
guess what there is no shame in that
game and we've got a sneak peek because
this year 30 new advertisers are in the
mix the prices are through the roof 30
second slots went for seven million
dollars
watch for 30 seconds i'm like where does
that money go it's ridiculous so here's
one with eugene levy for nissan
and they transformed him into a hardcore
action star
for this ad alongside real-life action
star dave bautista watch this ad eugene
levy
[Music]
well cock-a-doodle-doo
[Applause]
so much more to come yeah and you know
next we love it when people who've been
out of the spotlight for a minute make a
splash when they return on super bowl
sunday and guess who's back we haven't
seen her we haven't seen her but we'll
see her on sunday it's lindsay lohan
take a look at this
she's sleeping better than ever which
the paparazzi aren't thrilled about
she's even more productive trading dui's
for diy the verdict is
gorgeous maybe it's not what's gotten
into vince it's what lindsay's gotten
into hey william
welcome back
i
that's the thing about super bowl
commercials it's like they revive
careers you never know what you're gonna
get it's everybody's talking about it
the next day this is so fun
[Music]
you